I feel that the girl I used to play with
will grow up and realize that it was
molestation in the name of games and
complained to the police about me
we still travel in the same school bus
I hope my parents never find out that I
stole the money that went missing from
our house five years ago I feel guilty
because my dad was saving that money to
take my mom on their first trip abroad
I'm not a religious person so my biggest
fear is that God is real and everything
in the Bible is true my brother is very
depressed and suicidal no matter where I
am every time I hear an ambulance siren
I am afraid that something happened to
him I've had unprotected sex with
multiple boys I wanted to use protection
but the guys did it and I didn't want to
spoil their mood but now I'm scared that
if I get tested it will come back
positive for HIV I would say to ever had
the secret don't ever feel like they
anybody has control over your body more
than you do if it's something that you
are scared or nervous about and you
hesitate to do it don't do it as far as
getting to test it I would say
definitely get tested it hurts
to not know and if you're still having
sexual partners it's kind of like you
don't want to pass this on to them but
don't ever feel like you have to give
your body up to somebody or make them
feel uncomfortable one day I am afraid
that my friends will see me the real way
and that they will know of all the
jealousy and bitterness I have inside of
me towards them yeah one way I've seen
this a lot in my life is even just with
relationships and dating I've been
single for what feels like forever and
you know I've seen a lot of my friends
come in and out of like many
relationships in the time that I've not
experienced one sometimes I want to
place blame on myself and think that I'm
like being punished for something
because I'm not having those things that
other people are having and instead of
like looking at how I can change or how
I can improve it's easier to just be
jealous
towards other people I am a pansexual
fifteen-year-old girl living in a
predominantly Muslim country where
people in the lgbtq+ community are
arrested and sometimes stoned I'm afraid
that if I stay here I'll never be my
true self but the idea of leaving
everyone I know behind scares me just as
much the conflict makes me want to end
my life
it hurts me to read that because I've
had three or four times in my life where
people I've known have commit suicide
and so to be so close to that and
knowing that it occurs makes me want to
tell this person please don't do that
and it hurts to leave everyone you know
behind but in order for you to be who
you truly are
I feel like that's the right choice to
make and to be 15 years old that's the
other thing too these conflicts and
these feelings like going through and
maturing and having to struggle with
this is it's got to be hard I don't feel
like there's anyone who truly cares
about me I'm scared that one day if I
attempt suicide there'll be no one to
stop me I've had this fear a lot
especially in high school I was really
kind of afraid of myself and I was
worried that no one was gonna care or
stop me or they'd say if you were gonna
do it you would just do it you know you
wouldn't tell people but it's like you
tell people so that people stop you
I did I did when I was 17 it wasn't a
major attempt I would say it was kind of
just like an impulsive thing I started
just taking a bunch of my antidepressant
medications and I would just put them in
one by one and I got to a certain point
where I was just really sad for my
family and it was like I don't want them
to kind of just find me laying here and
I can fight to get better it's so hard
it is unbelievably hard when your mind
is against you but the regret comes from
well what if I succeeded and what if I
was meant to be this great thing or what
if I was meant to live the best life and
I just had to wait you know an extra
month or a year or even a day my little
brother passed away a month after he was
born
the only time I saw him was the day he
died since then nothing scares me more
than death that's devastating all right
I still remember like when my sister was
born and I just like looked at her in
the hospital crib it was just something
I never felt before the beauty of this
like new human who's who's part of your
blood and who's in your life now and to
have that taken away so soon is just a
nightmare death is definitely something
that's kept me up at night just the fear
and the feeling that everything you've
done in life basically disappears
because you're no longer existing with
that that is really scary and I think
what's helped me come to terms with that
is that even when you die the intangible
like thought of you still lives on in
people and I think this person's little
brother definitely is will stay with him
in his mind for the rest of his life and
it's just so tragic that his existence
was so limited I'm terrified of my mom
committing suicide after my dad left her
she
kept saying how she didn't know if she
knew how to live her life without him
I'm so scared I'm going to wake up one
day and find her dead body lying on my
bathroom ground jacks I feel like a lot
of us get to a point in which you reach
adulthood or maybe feel a moment where
your parents become like human to you
you're seeing your parent as a person
and the problems that they're going
through versus like being your parent is
this something you can talk to her about
you know is this something that you can
talk to somebody about and not hold it
in I feel like I got to a point where I
didn't talk about the deepest deepest
things that were inside of me and then
until they were just blowing up in my
face even if it's like writing it down
you know like releasing the thing that
is tugging at you
the cathartic nature of just like
letting it out is already in it of
itself like so hopeful